This lecture is about the collaborative
filtering.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of recommender
systems.
In particular, we're going to look at
the approach of collaborative
filtering.
You have seen this slide before when we
talked about the two strategies to
answer the basic question will user U
like item X.
In the previous lecture, we looked at
the item similarity.
That's content-based filtering.
In this lecture, we will look at the user
similarity.
This is a different strategy called a
collaborative filtering.
So first, what is collaborative
filtering?
It is to make filtering decisions for
individual user based on the judgments
of other users.
And that is, we say, we will infer
individual's interest or preferences
from that of other similar users.
So the general idea is the following.
Given a user U, we're going to 1st find
the similar users u_1 through u_m.
And then we're going to predict the user
preferences based on the preferences of
these similar users.
u_1 through u_m.
Now the user similarity
here can be judged based on their
similarity in preferences on a common
set of items.
Now here you can see the exact content
of item doesn't really matter.
We're going to look at the only the
relation between the users and items.
So this means this approach is very
general.
It can be applied to any items.
Not just the text options, so this
approach it would work well under the
following assumptions.
1st.
Users with the same interest where have
similar preferences.
Second, the users with similar
preferences probably share the same
interest.
So for example.
If the interest of the user is in
information retrieval, then we can
infer the user probably favor SIGIR
papers.
Alright, so those who are interested in
information retrieval research probably
all favor SIGIR papers.
That's the assumption that we make and if
this assumption is true,
Then it would help collaborative
filtering to work well.
We can also assume that if we see
people favor SIGIR papers,
then we can infer their interest is
probably information retrieval.
So in this simple examples it seems to
make sense.
And in many cases, such assumption
actually does make sense.
So another assumption we have to make
is that there are sufficiently large
number of user preferences available to
us.
So for example, if you see a lot of
ratings of users for movies, and those
indicate their preferences for movies,
and if you have a lot of such data,
then collaborative filtering can be
very effective.
If not, there will be a problem, and
that's often called cold start
problem.
That means you don't have many
preferences available, so the system
could not afford to take advantage of
collaborative filtering yet.
So let's look at the collaborative
filtering problem in a more formal way,
and so this picture shows that we are
in general considering a lot of users
showing we're showing M users here.
So u_1 through u_m and we also
considering a number of objects, let's
say N objects denoted as o_1 through
o_n and then we will assume that the
users will be able to judge those
objects and the user could for example
give ratings for those items, for
example, those items could be movies.
Could be products and then the users
would give ratings 1 through 5 let's
say.
So what you see here is that we have
shown some ratings available for some
combinations, so some users have
watched some movies they have rated
those movies.
They obviously won't be able to watch
all the movies and some users may
actually only watch a few movies.
So this is in general a sparse matrix.
So many items, many entries.
Have unknown values.
And what's interesting here is
we could potentially infer the value of
an element in this matrix based on other
values, and that's actually the central
question in collaborative filtering,
and that is we assume there's unknown
function here F that would map a pair
of a user and an object to the rating.
And we have observed some values of
this function.
And we want to infer the value of this
function for other pairs,
That with that don't have values
available here.
So this is very similar to other
machine learning problems where we know
the values of the function on some
training data sets and we hope to
predict the values of this function on
some test data, right?
So this is a function approximation.
And how can we figure out the function
based on the observed ratings?
So this is the setup.
Now there are many approaches to
solving this problem, and in fact this
is a very active research area, a reason
there are special conferences
dedicated to the problem.
R is the major conference devotes to the problem.
the problem.